[Musique]
il arrive
oui on va faire un film
et alors ce qui lui aucune importance
avec le champion que tu vois là on va
faire un film un champion enfin vous
aurez a beau avoir les meilleures
caméras les meilleurs réglages c'est pas
ça le plus important
ttt taratata françois taratata garde
discours de vendeurs de formation je
prenais de la première pluie moi j'suis
pas un singe tombé du nid
je suis pas un youyou qui titube tu nous
cache un truc et on sait pour une belle
image le plus important c'est la lumière
ok ok bonne humeur bien choisi
explique-nous
encore
[Musique]
tu es en train de me dire que la lumière
c'est le plus important a par définition
oui c'est pas compliqué à comprendre
visuellement y avait des films qu'en 20
ans tu vois qu'ils sont tournés avec de
vieilles caméra et qui aujourd'hui reste
encore des chefs-d'oeuvre et ça c'est en
partie lié à la gestion de la lumière à
abc a que ça à la maison j'ai en stock
dans pool ça devrait le faire
non moi je te parle de lumière
spécifique quand même parce que déjà il
n'y a pas qu'un seul type de lumière
savoir la distinguer c'est comme pour
tout il ya des nuances et des façons de
les mesurer
déjà tu peut distinguer la lumière
naturelle et la lumière artificielle en
lumière artificielle on a ce qu'on
appelle le tungstène des grosses
ampoules à filament mais c'est surtout
utilisé sur des très gros plateau pour
avoir une très grosse puissance
nous on va plutôt se baser sur la led le
gros avantage de la lumière artificielle
qu'on obtient avec toutes sortes
d'éclairage c'est qu'elle est constante
contrairement à la lumière naturelle
celle du soleil direct ou indirect qui
elle varie en fonction des moments de
l'année de la journée ou même tout
simplement de la météo l'avantagent de
la lumière naturelle c'est que c'est une
lumière puissante de qualité est
disponible tout le temps bon sauf la
nuit évidemment et surtout elle est
gratuite
parce qu'au niveau lumière artificielle
sakho chiffre est très loin c'est le
prix à payer pour avoir le contrôle
dessus j'ai regardé ce qu'il existait en
lumière pour la vidéo ya tout je
comprends rien alors on attend avant de
regarder et choisir il ya de tout sans
prendre en compte un bac waun of
t'allumes tête à tête un talus de temps
d'allumer
tu as une détente et un des temps
d'allumer times
quand on parle de lumière on utilise
souvent les qualificatifs de lumière
douce et lumière dure une lumière dure
c'est une forte concentration de lumière
depuis une zone réduite
ça crée généralement de forts contrastes
et surtout des zones très brillante pas
forcément esthétique par opposition à
une lumière douce ou diffuse qui elle va
être propagée par une zone large la
quantité de lumière va être répartie sur
une zone plus étendue à puissance égale
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que tu vois
souvent ces espèces de grands parapluies
avec un tissu blanc ce sont des
diffuseurs qui permettent de rendre la
lumière plus douce et ce phénomène tu
peut le remarquer par temps couvert
la lumière est bien mieux répartie
diffusées par les nuages puis à la
température aussi web à la lumière c'est
chaud quoi banon des fois c'est froid
il nous prend pour des cloches tu nous
prends pour des cloches
[Musique]
à
non non la lumière peut être chaude ou
froide et ça se mesure en kelvin nommé
degrés kelvin
bah oui oui oui c'est ça oui on parle
d'ailleurs en degrés kelvin parce que ça
correspond à la couleur que va prendre
un corps noir quand on chauffe un
morceau de métal sera d'abord rouge si
on chauffe mais il deviendra blanc puis
bleu si on chauffe encore plus pour
faire une idée une bougie c'est environ
1500 kelvin des ampoules classiques 3200
kelvin le soleil à midi c'est en 1600
kelvin est aussi l nuageux entre 7000 et
8000 cadiou d'où l'intérêt de faire une
bonne balance des blancs sur ta caméra
tu sais le petit cas d'intérêt de l'âge
tu te rappelles ce que je t'ai dit est
ce que ça veut dire photographie écrire
avec la lumière
c'est exactement ce dont on parle le
placement frontale c'est le plus pauvre
parce qu'il va venir écraser les
perspectives et ne créent pas de
contrastes ni dont c'est neutre mais
c'est pas hyper esthétique d'ailleurs si
on veut savoir où est placée la lumière
principal dans un plan les ombres seront
d'une grande aide
mais si on se décale un peu pour se
retrouver à 45° notre sujet ça devient
beaucoup plus intéressant ça va créer
des ombres donner du relief au visage
on va même voir apparaître le triangle
de hand or le triangle de rembrandt
c'est quoi c'est un élément esthétique
caractéristiques des portraits du
peintre qui peignait souvent ses modèles
avec une lumière de trois quarts qui
laisse systématiquement apparaître ce
petit triangle sur le haut de la joue du
sujet et tu peux t'amuser à chercher
dans les films et les séries
il est partout si tu l'as dans des
compositions c'est signe que ton
éclairage a du potentiel
on peut aussi éclairé latéralement dans
ce cas on a une moitié de visage qui
reste masques et ça donne généralement
un côté mystérieux au sujet voire même
ça peut souligner la dualité d'un
personnage
maintenant si je place mon éclairage
principale derrière mon sujet j'obtiens
un contre-jour ou une batte light là
aussi on est sur quelque chose d'assez
mystérieux très utilisé dans les drames
ou les moments de suspense le
contre-jour délimite la silhouette mais
on ne sait rien ou presque du
protagoniste
ensuite on peut se déplacer autour du
sujet mais on peut aussi positionné la
lumière plus ou moins au-dessus ou
au-dessous de lui généralement plus on
va au dessus plus c'est flatteur pour le
sujet et c'est aussi une solution pour
éviter les reflets dans les lunettes
al'inverse plus on va dessous plus on va
créer des ombres disgracieuses c'est un
procédé très utilisé dans les films
d'épouvanté ou d'horreur pour accentuer
les traits des monstres et autres
méchants c'est bon ça très bon et
comment je fais pour donner un look
dramatique pour ça tu peux jouer sur les
notions de l'eau qui est haï qui ce
qu'on appelle le lot qui s'est souvent
une atmosphère assez dark avec beaucoup
de contrastes lumineux
on a souvent un fond sombre et d
éclairage assez marquée des ombres ça
marche très bien dans des films
dramatiques
al'inverse on retrouve plus souvent la
technique du haïti dans les comédies les
films romantiques
là tout est clair et il ya peu de
différence d'intensité entre l'ariège et
le premier plan peut donc remarquer
c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus joyeux
et ça c'est quoi ça c'est un réflecteur
et ça c'est un diffuseur pour continuer
de sculpter la lumière il ne faut pas
oublier les notions de diffusion et de
réflexion la diffusion on l'a vu plus
haut ça permet de rendre une lumière
plus douce et d'éclairer une plus grande
surface
la réflexion elle permet de faire
rebondir la lumière d'une source est un
servir comme une seconde source atténuée
de la première on peut pour sa utiliser
des réflecteurs ou tout simplement un
élément blanc comme un mur ou même une
plaque de polystyrène d'ailleurs en
fonction du type de lumière qu'on veut
renvoyer les réflecteurs peuvent être
blanc argenté ou même doré pour une
lumière chaude donc
[Musique]
je mets une lumière et c'est tout a pas
forcément là où ça devient fun c'est
quand tu commences à faire des
combinaisons et ça tu le fais en
fonction du mood que tu veux donner à
des plans la combinaison la plus
fréquente c'est celle de l'éclairage en
trois points on va définir une source
principale là qu'il ait l'endroit où tu
la place va clairement déterminer
l'ambiance de ton plein nous on va la
placer deux trois quarts ça donne du
relief
mais ça reste plutôt standard ensuite on
a une source secondaire remplissage la
feel like hell elle va servir à
déboucher un peu les ombres créée par
notre qu'il ait mais on va lui donner
une plus faible intensité pour conserver
du contraste d'ailleurs on utilise
souvent un réflecteur pour la finale ait
pas besoin d'envoyer du lourd et enfin
la finition une battle ait un
contre-jour jeudi finition parce qu'elle
n'est pas indispensable mais ce petit
reflets sur les cheveux à l'arrière
c'est quand même plutôt cool et surtout
ça vient finir de détacher notre sujet
de l'arrière plan on dirige clairement
l'attention vers lui on peut y arriver
on va y arriver on va faire un film
on va faire un film non plus fort on va
faire un film
on va faire on va faire un film a fait
un film on fait un film on va faire un
film
on va faire un film on va faire un film
on va faire un film
on va faire vite on va faire ville bombe
a frappé
on va fermer
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas fait ça
[Applaudissements]